do you think men are the biggest threat
to women or the biggest Protectors of
women
I would say protectors because a woman
is not going to protect me no offense
but you're you're 20. if we was to have
this conversation was he 20 sorry if he
was to have this conversation I'm not
saying your experiences are irrelevant
I'm not I'm just saying I know at 20 I
had a completely different mindset to
you and once and this is one Min the
younger women because they're a little
bit more naive sometimes
easier to manipulate they don't really
have to deal with they like kids
there's enough I've seen a lot of things
though that generational trauma why
would a guy want a traumatized wife
right why would he pick that why would a
woman want an abuser why is your
immediate reaction because why are you
throwing that out there like no one was
talking about no no one wants a
traumatized person I'm not saying a man
should the man should sell for that yeah
at all but a man's God stepped back and
realize that he's part of the problem
okay why would a man who has never
abused you be part of the problem
um why I'm part of the problem you're
American you're a white woman you're
part of the problem how are you going to
sit there yeah
no no no I want you to stand on that
what what problem am I a part of
you think that being white and a woman
has benefited your life
do I think being white and a woman has
has it gone in your favor being a white
woman because I know statistically if I
was to go missing tonight on the way
home and and you did they're going to be
looking for me more than you I know that
that's not fair but that is the way he
is right and and that that's what
baffles me is when we could talk about
race we can see it like that but like
when we can like I said to you earlier
like I'm English I know full well if I'm
out and people are slower in the English
I ain't got nothing to say what can I
say it's true but but you're you're
making the assumption that that men are
slaughtering women and that's just not
the case and even if you're gonna you're
gonna talk about me what did I do
what do you mean
because you're saying you're part of the
problem but how how what we are we are
our speakers right who's who's who's
who's who's gonna be the ones to end
racism black people or white people it'd
be like me sitting there saying to you
you tell your son okay okay but but
otherwise they ain't gonna get they
ain't gonna get emotionally abused you
tell you it's on your end that's what
it's like saying but if I if I'm not
racist how am I part of the problem
because you've benefited no I understand
what you're saying and I agree like
that's what like if anything like I I
have a whole team in Nigeria that works
for me yeah and literally I've changed
their lives like they live like kings
but why did you change their lives is it
not because of colonization how is it
it's not colonization was it Nigeria it
wasn't because it was because I trained
them on how to cut clips and make things
I understand what you're saying I helped
them get a skill that could make them a
lot of money but even the way you said
it like I made their life better it was
a bit like white complex no it's not
white complex that's the way
we're talking about race we're talking
about racism okay so the problem I'm not
racist how am I a part of the problem
because I would imagine at some pay at
some point you've enabled some sort of
racism
because I am I'm white
racist towards me
have you enabled I think I've been in
situations where I've heard someone or
something been said and I haven't
addressed it like I should okay I'll
admit that because to me they're a bit
thick right they are thick not a bit so
I know I'm arguing with stupid do you
see what I mean that's their opinion but
I appreciate that is the problem because
I should be more vocal and say oh yeah
what the [ __ ] you talking about instead
of just ignoring it you know if you do
this one okay and I'm saying if you did
that that's a you problem why are you
projecting because I think I think if
you're white and you're saying that
you've never done that I think you're a
bit of a liar if that I've never done
what I think if you've been in a
situation where you've seen racism or
you've heard something and you haven't
pulled someone up on it I think you're
alive if I saw something racist I would
say something but that's the thing I
think at some point in your life you
probably haven't and that's what I'm
trying to say why are you making that
assumption when you don't know me why
are you making certain assumptions about
me when you don't I haven't made any
assumptions
I said older women are traumatized more
traumatized yeah 100 in general I never
said anything about you oh because I
thought earlier there was like a common
thing about this sounds like trauma if
if I said that it sounds like trauma it
was based off of things you said I
wouldn't make this up I wouldn't think I
wouldn't make an assumption about you
that was not based off of things you
said yeah should tell you what's hard to
listen to though is that is that you
will say that about that the trauma or
whatnot but if I say to you I I don't
think women are safe walking home late
at night or whatnot one first of all
you're quick to put it on me and I
should move and I should do this and I
should do that but at the same time
you're not really addressing where I'm
coming from because you're quickly
saying you're traumatized
I'm saying based on the words that come
out of your mouth you blame men for
things yeah and I say why don't you take
accountability and if you are feel
unsafe walking home alone why don't you
live somewhere else because I I believe
in taking personal accountability for
where your life is and for me
um I I don't you you see where I'm at I
don't live in the best area but I made
sure I lived in a place with security so
I could feel safe but you kind of you
probably have more choices than me I I
don't know but I'm but I'm saying I'm
saying I can imagine that there's a lot
of places to live in in England and you
there was not one apartment that you
were you had a gun to your head and they
said you must live here but that's what
happens with the council you you bid
what is
so that means you you've been working
since 18. you could have chosen to get
married you could have never wanted to
get married okay okay but yeah but you
could but it's a choice that's the whole
point of course
because it's not that you're punished
but you're making other people pay for
your bad decisions the government and
people pay taxes into the government if
it's the same way it's in the US I don't
completely understand Section 8 but if
it's government assisted housing that is
you not being financially responsible
and you put yourself in that situation
but this is what I'm kind of saying I
didn't want to say this to you because I
knew you would say this and it weren't
because I was avoiding responsibility we
can have a talk after and talk about my
situation that's fine but the problem is
you are directing it more at me than
anything else
with what's going on is that you're
based in your scenario like just I don't
know what's happening in your life
and I respect it but
the majority I don't know no I mean just
by the little I'm not saying little but
there probably was like I don't know how
many men you probably being abused or
you know by but you're judging that no
no it's a lot but this is what I tried
to say earlier I'm not stupid so if I
was the only person I've never known to
have been followed home or touched I
wouldn't have these opinions
there are so many men in the world there
is but you've also got men that are
being kidding and graping and killing
and not getting the reaper
yeah but the thing is why why hang on
this is the thing why is it that you
keep hanging on yeah the trauma and the
negativity
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait when men have shown themselves like
we said earlier in this situation in the
show to build the world in which you
live men have built the world in which
you live they've built this how they
probably built this this apartment you
probably got here on the public
transport they built that men have
literally built the um the world in
which you live in and you think it's
okay to just sit there and be like I
feel like men are bad women men are [ __ ]
more than you that probably won't have
the same thought process as you do you
know who sorry so is that so there's
definitely woman in the world that's
gone through more than what you've gone
through that won't happen of course but
there's women that I volunteer a nature
reserve in um East ham and I'm dealing
with uh the majority of the volunteers
are over 70. what would you teach your
child or your card your little siblings
or in what sort of about men because
I've got a son
[Music]
is your son gonna grow up to be a
predator then
um I know because I'm teaching him how
to treat women I'm not letting it be
Society telling them I'm not not letting
it be a toxic man
no no what are you listening when you're
listening to songs talking about raping
women when you're watching films where
you're watching audience oh if you know
I can show you guys I think I think it's
what I think is interesting here is how
like you you use very minute kind of um
anomaly like situations far out of Norm
to justify very extreme beliefs I don't
think so I think I could say whatever I
wanted and you would never agree because
that's one thing I know you you seem to
avoid accountability at every level
okay for example you say if Paul says
say for example your housing this
Alleyway thing you're talking about
right and if anyone says maybe you could
move somewhere else you could do it this
way I did you seem to always look for a
reason to not have control agency over
these situations
why is it victim blaming to say where
you're at in life is your own fault it's
based off the choices you're making at
18 one thing but you're 32 you're a
grown woman yeah you've had over a
decade to make double choices yeah and
if you're on government housing and
you've made poor decisions to get there
like that's something you know you can't
pay you know it's it's not all
subsidized you do know that don't you so
I told you I don't understand so you're
you're kind of almost going with like a
narrative that is all paid for well you
you don't know that you do people that
make good financial decisions end up on
this government housing typically it all
depends their life you don't you don't
of course but there's going to be the
answer is no you can't do if you're
trying to scam the system okay so Tim
I'm just asking okay just in the room
you guys are from here typically no no
okay do people that are on the housing
that she described typically make good
financial decisions no you have people
in new development government housing
and they're trying to ladder up and buy
the housing but no they don't it's not I
mean let's just be honest no they
probably made some poor choices to get I
should tell you what it was I moved out
young that was why and it kind of set me
back a little bit because I I moved out
young so you're facing and this is where
it's this is where I get annoyed because
you've had over a decade no no no no
you're you're again this is the thing
because I'm from what you've said if I
was to go home tonight get a bus go down
an Alleyway and get brutally great your
answer would be well you should have
done something to not put yourself in
the alleyway
is what you basically said
I would say press charges but but they
never get done that's not necessarily
true it is I mean let's let's there are
many situations where women have falsely
recruit huge men of things and they have
gone to jail for it
that's the narrative to say to take away
for the fact of how many people are
great and how many people don't go to
prison for it is it easy to say oh yeah
but false rather accept validation okay
okay I'll give you an example there is a
guy in the U.S he was in college and a
girl said that he raped her or that she
that he raped her right and then they
released security footage of her pulling
him back to the dorm kissing him
um he was pulling away from her she
still kissed him pulling him back to her
dorm and he still got kicked out of
college because that's terrible yeah but
that never says I'm saying to you that's
terrible I'm not saying he deserves that
it's about that's what I'm saying and
I'm saying what I would say is there are
situations as a woman you should try not
to put yourself in
and have a son you you have yeah and I'm
saying sorry like
they're I'm not okay you have a son
there's women out here that actually lie
yeah yeah say one day a woman says
you're gonna believe the woman over your
son I would find that one hard it all
depends on the sort of man no no no but
listen it all depends on the sort of man
that I raised do you see what I mean I
might feel like I can raise that man
that man but you don't know him outside
Gucci I answer that you ask you a
question though say if I said to you now
someone graved me would you and it turns
out I'm a liar right I've lied about it
all wouldn't you do you not as much as
lying about it is terrible oh [ __ ] as
much as lying about it is terrible isn't
being the greatest worse yeah there we
are then yeah
I don't understand that actually hold on
so she lies but it's it's worse that she
could have been telling them no no no no
no no no no no not at all you're
twisting it to make it seem to me like
if if a man is falsely accused of rape
okay great sorry sorry sorry the chances
are he's more likely to have done it
than not and that's statistically bad
wow more likely to be graved by another
man than you are falsely accused no no
no no you're talking about you're
talking about you're talking about sorry
hang on you're talking about the
accusation you're saying if a man is
accused of it yeah yeah he's more likely
to have that's statistically backed hang
on hang on if you could Google it I
don't know I'm asking like you're a
misandridge
I don't think I I just I just think if a
woman come to me and said look I've been
graped by this person I would rather
believe her and find out she's a liar
then then turn turn my back on her and
believe a great picture as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible